my relationships like when it comes to
sex so if someone were to ask me like
hey dominate me I'll just be like Oh cuz
you're the other way around
that's not something that you could
really play well mm-hmm just gotta catch
us take some acting classes you know I
know dude the girl that I always tell
you about the one that I've known her
for [ __ ] forever she's a she's a very
high-end escort oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah she posted the funniest [ __ ] she
posted a picture of a conversation
between her and her sister and it was a
picture of a pair of Christian Louboutin
shoes the one that I'm that I saw it was
about like I want to say like 1800
ollars God yeah and she told her sister
hey when I come home for Christmas try
this on and the caption for the photo
said these shoes don't fit means I'm
letting my sister try it on I had to
[ __ ] a guy in the ass with a remote
control for this and I'll be damned if
these things go to waste
oh my god yeah and I've gotten into like
very long in-depth conversations with
her about being an escort like how like
what what do you do and she said you
know the weird thing is whenever people
think of sex work they think oh I gotta
[ __ ] these ugly dudes that I don't want
to be around but she's not [ __ ] them
she's not she's well one she's not
[ __ ] them all the time cuz all I
really wants companionship and two she
gets to choose who her clients are also
choice yeah yeah exactly and she showed
me photos of some her clients these
dudes are handsome rich dudes like in
their 30s that look like male models
dude my majors so what is it is it's
it's a mental thing then like they want
to be the [ __ ] maybe because they're
like [ __ ] top dog all the time
exactly like they like being they want
to be on the other you [ __ ] sick [ __ ]
or like she lives in San Francisco like
one of the most expensive [ __ ] places
in the world oh yeah yeah yeah and she
lives right near the UM the the finance
tower like something a really rich
ballin place and these guys are so rich
that they they're they're so busy yeah
they can't find time to find female
companionship to date or whatever so
sometimes they just want to get off and
she said you know 80% of the time I
don't even [ __ ] them I like there's this
one guy that pays her thousands just to
chill smoke weed eat
and watch Game of Thrones with him that
sounds nice that is so pleasant well
what kind of [ __ ] remote was that guy
[ __ ] with I hope that was like a Roku
remote and none of my bees like big ones
I hope it wasn't a Comcast cable box
remote that shits Robert oh do they meet
in a in a in a hotel or their house
apparently what they do is and I've read
about this I saw some red it's who she
would sit at a bar at like the Four
Seasons or the ritz-carlton very
expensive places she would sit there in
a bar have a few drinks read her book
whatever and that's how she finds her
clients they they just come up to her
and they're just like you you stick
[ __ ] remote no how the start of that
conversation I mean so you go to the
ritz-carlton and then what makes them
think that she is the person to [ __ ] him
in the ass yeah right with a balloon I
don't know I I think it's how she
presents herself like cuz she's she's
not a bad-looking girl dude she's pretty
her body is tight like she looks amazing
she's older than me she's probably
somewhere in her like mid-30s or so and
she looks great like and I think it's
just how she presents herself she's very
open like this girl is [ __ ] wild like
I've known her went back when I was
go-go dancing when she was like before
the sex work you know and this [ __ ] is
wild she parties you know and I think
it's just really how she presents
herself because when I first met her
like you can kind of tell I looked at I
was like you are insane and super fun I
love it you know I use don't kill but
yeah and she's one of those people and
it's just like and people open up to her
and they can talk to her very you know
comfortably and freely I have no idea
how the conversation would start but I
think the way she presents herself I
want you to try to be an escort right
now okay okay okay so you're at bar so
just in San Francisco there's jazz music
playing in the background keep it
family matters the family matters
playing in the background right now
right so you are wearing what if you're
an escort what are you wearing super
tight skirt very expensive heels
expensive designer purse and jewelry all
right mm-hmm you look like you have
money because these men will look at you
and be like she has money how does she
have that there's only two three all
three ways so she can have that one
she's successful herself too rich as
husband three she's an escort oh yeah so
you can't come in there looking all
raggedy and [ __ ] okay well my name is
raggedy Richard Richard now it's just
piss I don't know there's a lot of
Richard's I don't like those Richards I
like to that what like so he comes up
and he's just gonna look at you okay so
what's going on you look you know you
want to get a drink or so okay with the
13th well you clearly haven't had Louie
the 76 I don't know [ __ ] about alcohol
let me get the Louie the 76 for this a
beautiful lady here we poor Doug look
look look in the back I'm pouring that
drink we slide it over you're drinking
we're chatting it up blah blah blah blah
so where did this conversation go to for
me to assume that you're an escort it
would you would have the initiation yeah
I think so I have no idea how she does
it but I really I really did so what is
so what will you do oh you know just
some business here and their business
what type of business um [ __ ] yeah
you really could it be an escort could
you look at you in a fake situation
I don't know wouldn't like I'm on the
spot fine I'm gonna be the escort man
you're gonna be Richard Richard the
[ __ ] [ __ ] rich rich [ __ ]
all right I'm [ __ ] 'red yeah you're
[ __ ] you're bitchin Pryor Richard all
right Richard Pryor and I'm [ __ ] Suze
this the sex mink okay
I'm by the way I'm smoking a really long
sing
smoking the cigarette that's attached to
a gold tip in the secret said okay yes
I'm doing I'm sure you might watch right
now yeah all right and then from what I
learned from her um what is it
rich men never wear socks oh okay rich
dress shoes and no socks okay that's
what's going on right now I'm over here
smoking my long cigarette and I also
smell like [ __ ] juice here we go so
what are you doing here that's the sound
of be uh smoking my bubble pipe of a
detective or here we go okay you come
here oh I don't know do I
I don't know I see you a few times a
week here and I just want to see you
know what do you do here do you work
around here does it look like I work
here you couldn't afford B I can't
afford you
oh that's really good segue holy [ __ ]
that was BAM look at that oh you're a
good ho
dude call me Priscilla the [ __ ] juice
dude that's what I'm telling you right
now dude I was born the wrong sex what
if you did that and he was like what do
you mean I can't afford you you think I
don't make money
I don't know why don't you prove it to
me I'm trying to get [ __ ] tonight out
of all these years between David and
Gina everyone thought Gina was the ho
but David was a clear better ho dude I'm
a [ __ ] ho you know the weird thing is
from late comments I've been getting
recently used to always be damn Gina
must be a ho and it actually shifted now
- what - damn Gina when are you gonna
get married